[Musique]
la place de la Concorde à Paris est
rapidement devenue le centre du
rassemblement les manifestants ont
convergé par milliers pour faire
entendre leurs colères au gouvernement
j'ai honte pour le gouvernement qui
continue qu'ils écoutent pas
le peuple quelle utilité c'est juste
Emmanuel Macron qui a dit il faut cette
réforme des retraites ils savent
queboute là-dessus plutôt dans la
journée c'est à quelques pas de là à
l'Assemblée nationale que le parcours
législatif de la réforme des retraites a
pris fin et sous les huées sans que les
députés puissent se prononcer
on n'a pas mis bâti par les deux
assemblées écartés on ne peut pas faire
de Paris sur l'avenir de nos retraites
cette réforme est nécessaire sans
certitude d'obtenir une majorité d'appui
le gouvernement a préféré déclencher le
49,3 une procédure constitutionnelle qui
permet de contourner le vote des élus
après des semaines de contestation cette
décision a soulevé l'indignation de
l'opposition
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la séance est suspendue
d'empêcher l'expression de la volonté du
peuple français au travers de ces
représentants ils n'ont pas réussi à
trouver une majorité parce qu'ils
étaient mauvais cette réforme était
injuste mal préparé mal conçu les
parties d'opposition au premier
traitement la tenue d'un vote de
confiance mais il n'est pas clair pour
l'instant que les élus seront assez
nombreux à les appuyer pour faire tomber
le gouvernement
et bien Manon avec les syndicats et que
tout soit fait qui permet que la loi
soit retirée
Atari la grève des éboueurs dont les
impacts sont visibles depuis des jours
dans les rues se poursuivra jusqu'à au
moins le lundi
aujourd'hui l'activité de certains ports
du pays a été bloquée les grands
syndicats assurent que le mouvement
social est loin d'être terminé de
nouvelles manifestations sont déjà
prévues au cours de la prochaine semaine
l'Inter syndical continu à exiger le
retrait de cette réforme en toute
indépendance dans des actions calmes et
déterminées le coup de force du
gouvernement n'a pas mis fin au
mouvement de contestation il a même
alimenté les frustrations comme l’ont
montré les rassemblements spontanés à
Paris mais aussi dans plusieurs villes
du pays ici Raphaël Bouvier au clair
Radio-Canada Le Puy-en-Velay